we got a big surprise it's even better
this year no more back and forth that
Christmas does not do in the back of
nope they just said to him but together
Christmas like a normal family has a
Christmas hello grandpa Kurt my dad is
gonna scoff at everything we do your
father hasn't met the new of all dusty I
mean who wouldn't be impressed with you
there dear God it's gonna come off weird
dusty but he's beautiful
why don't you bring the car around I'm
not the driver I'm Brad stepdad my dad's
coming to sweater he wears a red sweater
so I can see him in a crowd so this code
dad's thing you gotta ask another man's
permission to see your own kid
everything is rock-solid between me and
bread in fact best friends really bad
thank you
stop it oh good cuz we're boys here's
the game plan
you wanna be that one that she tells you
about all of her problems with the guys
she's actually dating it's called the
friendzone no no no the worst advice
anyone could give you you want to be
like Brad being the friendzone you want
to be like dad and get the end zone oh
gosh that's piercing eyes like a
velociraptor don't you see what he's up
to you think she would be a harping dad
please
no I'm not harboring anything I just
want to find the perfect together
Christmas tree you don't think I can
operate a chainsaw
right cut down cellphone tower I think
Brad's dead again don't you want to
spend the harness the one true real dad
driving all the way up here just to get
back in it
yep they opening up the heart of Brad
all the part was wide open and it's
Fleet Week this is getting good boys you
throw that we are no longer code ads you
got a pump fake that thing all night you
gotta take a shot Brad huh he's never
played sports ever what what maybe it's
stuck to his hand no what does she not
with
[Applause]
you